In cinema, a little allure goes a long way.
When it comes to unintentional wardrobe malfunctions,
however, the effect can be more humorous than
titillating.
We're here to show you a handful of our favorite
wardrobe flubs.
There's something special about the Star Wars
film universe's far-reaching, wide-ranging
appeal.
Though creator George Lucas reportedly owned
up to purposely making his prequel installments
more friendly to a younger audience, a vast
majority of Star Wars fanatics are adults.
And apart from an innuendo or two likely meant
to make the older crowd chuckle, the movies
have remained largely squeaky clean -- with
one notable exception.
In Return of the Jedi, actress Femi Taylor
portrays Oola, the green-skinned slave dancer
Jabba the Hutt holds captive in his palace.
Before Oola meets her grisly death at the
mouth of a hungry Rancor, Jabba makes her
strut about in her skimpy outfit while he
watches.
When he grabs hold of Oola's chain during
the sequence, he causes a wardrobe malfunction
that makes her costume reveal something you'd
never think you'd see in a Star Wars movie.
The slip happens in the blink of an eye, but
it definitely ended up in the movie.
The fact that Lucas was a stickler for scrubbing
up footage for home releases makes it especially
bizarre that this malfunction didn't end up
on the cutting room floor.
Watchers of Vanilla Sky aren't left wanting
additional adrenaline-pumping action, an extra
smattering of stirring sci-fi, or more eyebrow-raising
decisions that make Tom Cruise's character
seem genuinely dangerous.
One of the most noteworthy scenes in the film
involves such a move made by Cruise's David
Aames, who captures Cameron Diaz's Julianna
Gianni, his one-time lover, and straps her
to the bed.
Diaz, wearing a sheer dress, attempts to flip
herself over on the mattress, and in doing
so, accidentally shifts the top of the garment
out of place.
The actress is quick to fix the wardrobe malfunction
mid-scene, pulling the gown into its original
position, but the chest-exposing take wound
up in the film's final cut.
Arnold Schwarzenegger has been in the spotlight
since his days as one of the world's foremost
champion bodybuilders.
Over the years, he has starred in a plethora
of blockbuster action flicks and, of course,
governed the state of California.
But even the former "Governator" has suffered
an incident on the set, experiencing a wardrobe
malfunction countless fans have noticed.
During the opening scene of 1984's The Terminator,
Arnold Schwarzenegger walks around in his
birthday suit before he gets the chance to
cover up.
Low lighting, clever distant camera angles,
and the stereotypically poor quality of the
original 1980s footage preserve Schwarzenegger's
dignity for the most part, but those naughty
bits still made it into the movie — the
remastered Blu-ray edition shows the actor
stark naked and on full display as he approaches
a group of young ruffians.
"I think this guy's a couple cans short of
a six pack."
"You're clothes.
Give them to me."
In the 1980s, VHS cassettes were the state-of-the-art
form of media distribution, and without an
internet, salacious rumors and news about
movies spread via word of mouth.
These are the factors that spread the notion
that there is a moment of accidental near
nudity in the 1985 horror comedy Teen Wolf.
Pause the tape at just the right moment, the
rumor said, and viewers would see an extra
in a crowd shot with the fly of their pants
wide open, and the white underwear beneath
fully visible.
The scene in question is a high school basketball
game in which the titular teen wolf Scott
Howard aggressively competes.
The crowd cheers, and a shot of a spectator
in the grandstands made it into the final
cut of the film, and the zipper of their pants
is indeed unzipped.
This definitely isn't the most graphic example
on this list, but it's nonetheless a solid
example of a surprising editing mistake.
Considering that Samuel L. Jackson has previously
expressed his view that nude scenes are, quote,
"extremely awkward" to film, you'd be right
to assume that the prolific actor has never
in his decades-long career sauntered around
in his birthday suit for a movie.
As it happens, however, you'd be wrong.
In the 2001 drama pic The Caveman's Valentine,
Jackson plays a paranoid schizophrenic man
who becomes inextricably involved in a murder
mystery.
At one point, he strips down and struts past
a mirror in a scene likely meant to show off
only his buttocks.
But, as most malfunctions go, a lot more was
caught on camera.
In a flashbulb moment while his backside is
on display, viewers can see Jackson's frontside,
too.
The Caveman's Valentine never got a Blu-ray
release, meaning no one will ever see a high-resolution
shot of Jackson's nether region, so his dignity
is at least partly preserved.
The 1981 Australian drama war film Gallipoli
is noteworthy for a few reasons: It took home
a grand total of eight Australian Film Institute
awards, boomed in the box office down under,
earned a Golden Globe nomination for Best
Foreign Film in 1982, and fared well with
critics.
It's also become known for a vastly different
reason: Gallipoli features a bit more of Mel
Gibson.
A then-25-year-old Gibson shows off everything
he's got during a scene in which his character
— Archy Hamilton, the stockman and sprinter
with his sights set on the Australian Imperial
Force — sheds his colors to go for a swim
with his soldier pals.
When he dives down to the seafloor, we end
up seeing more of Gibson than we should have.
He clearly wasn't given any costume modifications
to help prevent any slippage, and the shot
wasn't clipped out of the theatrical or home
release versions of the film.
Bad Boys II is a small slice of heaven for
any fan of the buddy cop and action-comedy
genres.
It's got a leading duo who work off one another's
attitudes and push each other's buttons; a
high-stakes mission the pair have to embark
on; a seemingly indomitable villain; and the
ubiquitous beautiful and badass woman who
ends up a love interest for one of the protagonists.
Gabrielle Union is that more-than-a-pretty-face
character in the film, so it's unsurprising
that she's seen sporting some revealing outfits.
One in particular is a little too low-cut,
however.
In a scene where Union's character chucks
a gun toward a live minefield and then ducks
for cover, her cut-out dress slides sideways
to reveal her nipple.
In real time, the malfunction is a bit hard
to spot, but slow down the footage just a
tad, and you'll see Union's chest clear as
day.
Denzel Washington leads the 1991 crime thriller
Ricochet, playing LAPD Detective-Lieutenant
and Assistant District Attorney Nicholas Styles.
During a locker room scene, an unclothed Washington
leaps up from the bench to hide behind a locker
door when a woman enters the men-only zone.
In this split moment, his manhood gets a fraction
of a second of fame.
An untrained eye wouldn't be able to zero
in on the explicit shot, but if you look just
carefully enough, it's definitely there.
There Will Be Blood is the story of a greed-driven
oil man named Daniel Plainview, fascinatingly
portrayed with shocking brutality by Daniel
Day-Lewis.
The actor received his second of three Best
Actor Academy Awards for his work as a driving
force of the California oil boom in the late
1800s and early 1900s.
Plainview aggressively cajoles and bends rivals
and allies alike to his will, traipsing all
over others metaphorically when he's not traipsing
literally around his land holdings dotted
with big, noisy oil derricks.
Such labor requires a solid, reliable, and
sturdy pair of work boots, and Plainview can
be seen wearing a pair of brown leather ones.
They look suitably expensive, but they also
look unsuitably modern.
During a moment of rest, the camera shows
the bottom of Plainview's boots, and they
bear a waffle pattern, the kind found on early
Nike running shoes.
The latter is widely acknowledged as the originator
of that kind of groove — which it pioneered
in 1972, decades after the California oil
boom.
Dazed and Confused is one of the best teen
movies of all time, a personal and casually
realistic look at the night after the last
day of school in 1976.
Not a whole lot happens, just like what happens
when real kids get together, both then and
now.
Early in the film, various characters cruise
around town in their cars.
During a scene shot from the point of view
of one of these teens as they navigate traffic,
a motorcyclist can be seen wearing a vest-type
jacket adorned with the skull logo used by
the punk band The Misfits.
Though this skull drawing can be traced back
to the 1930s, it's still likely an anachronism.
Dazed and Confused takes place in 1976, a
year before the band formed, and five years
before it publicly unveiled the skull logo.
Pulp Fiction, possibly Quentin Tarantino's
most beloved film, thoroughly earns the R
rating bestowed upon it by the Motion Picture
Association of America.
The F-word is uttered more than 260 times,
a character suffers a near fatal drug overdose,
and grisly violence is scattered throughout.
"What country are you from?"
"What?"
"What ain't no country I ever heard of.
They speak English in 'What'?"
Despite all that tawdry stuff, there's only
one bit of nudity, and it was seemingly accidental.
During a quiet moment when Butch hides out
with his girlfriend Fabienne after refusing
to throw a boxing match, he takes a shower.
When he gets out, he grabs a towel while Fabienne
brushes her teeth, but Willis doesn't hold
the fabric high enough, thus revealing his
manhood to moviegoers.
Later, when Pulp Fiction aired on television,
the towel was digitally stretched to cover
the uncovered parts of Butch.
The works of 19th century English author Jane
Austen enjoyed a surge of popularity in the
1990s.
Arguably the most successful '90s Austen-based
project was 1995's Sense and Sensibility,
which won cast member Emma Thompson a screenwriting
Oscar and elevated the outside-the-U.K. fame
of her co-stars Kate Winslet and Hugh Laurie.
The intricately realized film also has a few
modern touches, although one was clearly unintentional:
With Colonel Brandon looking on, Mr. Palmer
reluctantly holds an infant.
The baby's outerwear is Regency-appropriate,
but its other garments are not.
The little one wears a 20th century-style
disposable diaper, which certainly wasn't
available in 1810.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.